hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live kurz vor der Landtagswahl in Bayern
ein Skandal der nicht nur
Ministerpräsident Söder unter Druck
bringt sondern der mehr ist es geht um
ein menschenverachtendes antisemitisches
Flugblatt das sein Vize Hubert Aiwanger
zu seinen Schulzeiten in der Tasche
hatte Aiwanger sagt er hat es nicht
verfasst sondern nach bekannt werden
übernimmt seinen Bruder die
Verantwortung dafür es bleiben offene
Fragen und die sollen heute in einer
Sondersitzung vor dem
Koalitionsausschuss geklärt werden seit
10 Uhr 30 sitzen sie hier in der
bayerischen Staatskanzlei zusammen
Aiwanger soll sich erklären persönlich
Stellung nehmen ob die Aktion
Konsequenzen hat das ist heute bei uns
Thema das verfolgen wir live für euch
wir schalten auch zur Pressekonferenz in
dem Moment wenn sie losgeht kommentiert
mit direkt im Stream oder per Mail denn
wir sind für euch live dabei und
schalten jetzt zuerst am Anfang direkt
mal nach München zu meiner Kollegin
Patricia Schäfer die das ganze schon
seit Tagen für uns beobachtet uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist hallo Patricia hallo
Alisa Patricia welches Szenarien welche
Konsequenzen sind da denn jetzt heute
denkbar
nun es ist klar also Aiwanger wurde
einbestellt es ist ein
Koalitionsausschuss einberufen das ist
noch nie in der Koalition zwischen
Freien Wählern und CSU der Fall gewesen
anders als in Berlin trifft sich dieser
informelle Ausschuss hier eigentlich
quasi nie die haben recht geräuschlos
regiert bisher aber jetzt ist das nötig
geworden die Spitzen bei der Parteien
sind also in der Staatskanzlei und
sitzen zusammen wir wissen dass
Ellwanger und Söder als erste in die
Staatskanzlei gegangen sind dort
angekommen sind man kann also davon
ausgehen dass es wahrscheinlich erstmal
ein Gespräch unter vier Augen gehabt
bevor dann die größere Runde zusammen
trat und es wird jetzt darum gehen wie
weiter Söder muss sich als
Ministerpräsident nun verhalten wie er
mit seinem stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsident Norbert Aiwanger
verfahren will nach bekannt werden
dieser Flugblatt Affäre ähm es gibt
verschiedene Szenarien die kleinste
Möglichkeit wäre einmal einfach
auszutauschen als stellvertretender
Ministerpräsident der freie wählerchef
würde dann einfach dieses Amt verlieren
ansonsten würde alles gleich bleiben die
nächst höhere Eskalationsstufe wäre zu
sagen ja wir machen die Koalition mit
den Freien Wählern weiter aber ohne
eiwanger das hat wiederum das Problem
dass die Freien Wähler in Bayern quasi
Ellwangen sind auf seine er ist das Zug
fährt er bindet die meisten Wähler er
bekommt den meisten Applaus in den
Bierzelten er ist derjenige der hier so
viele Stimmen holt für die Freien Wähler
die dritte und sehr härteste kurz
unterbrechen an dieser Stelle denn wir
sehen Markus Söder der jetzt das
Rednerpult betritt und schalten jetzt
live drauf wir sehen uns danach wieder
gar nicht grüße Dich und Pressen auf der
Kabinettssitzung und weiteren
Gremiensitzungen
bitte um Verständnis dass sie heute nur
in Statement geben wird und keine Fragen
im Anschluss dazu Ministerpräsident dr
Markus Söder
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
schönen Tag
ich habe heute als Ministerpräsident die
Freien Wähler natürlich auch Hubert
Aiwanger zu einem
sonderkonditionsausschuss eingestellt
ich und wir wollten uns ein Bild machen
ein eigenes Bild machen und einen
persönlichen Eindruck gewinnen über die
Debatte der letzten Tage klar ist das
heads Flugblatt ist ekelhaft widerlich
es ist übelster nazischargon
so wie das Flugblatt auch geschrieben
ist merkt man dass da auch eine ganz
andere Energie dahinter steckt das ist
nicht nur ein dummer jungen Streich oder
eine bloße Jugendsünde
daher sind die Vorwürfe die dort in dem
Raum standen natürlich schwer und sie
wiegen auch schwer
allein der Verdacht
beschädigt das Ansehen Bayerns und
natürlich auch die persönliche
Glaubwürdigkeit des bayerischen
Wirtschaftsminister Hubert Albert
am Ende einer Debatte kein Rest Zweifel
bleiben es darf keine Hängepartie werden
es muss rasch geklärt werden es gibt
keinen Platz für Antisemitismus in der
bayerischen Staatsregierung und es ist
wichtig Staatsregierung oder ein
Wirtschaftsminister dann wieder
handlungsfähig sind
als Ministerpräsident trage ich die
Verantwortung vernünftig zu entscheiden
das heißt
fair Objektiv
seriös zu bewerten und am Ende abzuwägen
hier geht es nicht um Vorverurteilung
oder gar ein Übermaß klar ist aber auch
es muss geklärt werden und es muss eine
klare Distanzierung von dem verzeihen
Sie es bitte Dreck erfolgen
die Recherchen aus Süddeutschen Zeitung
allein reichen nicht aus die sind
bislang nur anonyme Quellen
keine weiteren Belege
da ist es wichtig um diese
Verdachtsmomente auszuräumen
und jeden Verdacht zweifelsfrei zu
zerstreuen Gelegenheit zu Äußerung zu
geben
wir haben heute Hubert Aiwanger gehört
wir haben ihn befragt
die heutigen Aussagen reichen aber nicht
aus
definitiv nicht aus für eine
abschließende Bewertung und Klärung es
blieben und bleiben viele Fragen offen
der war gerade weil in den letzten Tagen
ist immer wieder widersprüchliche
Details in der Öffentlichkeit gab und
jeden Tag sich die Sache in die Sachlage
etwas anders entwickelt hat haben sich
daraus noch mehr Fragen ergeben
da haben wir uns klar darauf festgelegt
dass wir eine schriftliche Beantwortung
möchten von Fragen
wir werden 25 Fragen die wir
zusammenstellen an Hubert Aiwanger zur
Beantwortung geben er selbst hat
zugesagt diese Fragen nach bestem Wissen
und Gewissen beantworten zu wollen dies
ist wichtig für das weitere Fortgang für
die Glaubwürdigkeit auch für mögliche
Debatten im Bayerischen Landtag die er
denkbar sind
und so wird alberner ist auch bereit
wenn noch vorhandene schulakten da sind
die zu öffnen und damit auch für
maximale Transparenz zu sorgen
ich finde es ist einfach wichtig auch
mit solch einer Beantwortung reinen
Tisch zu machen Klarheit für alle zu
schaffen damit man dann hoffentlich
vernünftig weiterarbeiten kann
bis zur abschließenden Klärung solange
kein neuer Beweis vorliegt oder bisher
gesagt ist komplett widerlegt werden
kann
wäre eine Entlassung aus dem Amt eines
Staatsministers ein Übermaß
im Übrigen muss man auch bedenken die
Sache ist tatsächlich über 30 Jahre her
und er hat sich jedenfalls heute sehr
klar davon distanziert
ich sage aber auch es ist jetzt kein
Freispruch oder Freibrief
viele Menschen sind zutiefst empört und
verunsichert und haben diese Fragen so
wie wir auch
das heißt es darf jetzt auch nichts mehr
dazu kommen
schon jetzt ist in der Tat der Schaden
für den Ruf von Bayern hoch und auch der
persönlichen Glaubwürdigkeit
ich möchte aber auch allen sagen die
darüber spekulieren die Zusammenarbeit
mit den freien wählen als Ganzes hat
sich bewährt sie ist gut und wir wollen
sie auch fortsetzen
es gibt auch keinen Anlass etwas daran
an dieser Zusammenarbeit zu ändern
Koalitionen hängen übrigens auch nicht
an einer einzigen Person
es gibt mit oder ohne eine Person im
Staatsamt ganz genau so
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren es
ist ärgerlich
dass wir uns jetzt genau in dieser Phase
auch zu diesem Zeitpunkt
mit diesen Themen beschäftigen müssen
aber Dinge die da sind müssen geklärt
werden und das Minister was ist meine
Aufgabe zusammenzuhalten
das Gefühl und Verständnis viele
aufzunehmen aber wie in der Tat seriös
abzuwägen und dann am Ende zu
entscheiden
jetzt warten wir auf die Antwort und
werden dann und können dann eine
entsprechend abschließende Bewertung
vornehmen
der Ball und die Möglichkeit zu Klärung
dieser Frage der Ball liegt wieder bei
den Freien Wählern Hubert Aiwanger und
wir hoffen sehr dass wir am Ende danach
schlauer als heute sind und warten die
weitere Entwicklung ab für den heutigen
Tag wie gesagt 25 Fragen an Hubert
Aiwanger und wir hoffen sehr auf eine
rasche das wurde uns zugesagt auf eine
rasche und umfangreiche Beantwortung
dieser Fragen die für viele Menschen
aber übrigens auch für meine Parteien
für mich ganz persönlich von
entscheidender Bedeutung sind
herzlichen Dank
herzlichen Dank danke für Interesse
denn der Ministerpräsident Markus Söder
von der CSU war das der sich geäußert
hat gerade nur in einem Statement Fragen
von Journalistinnen und Journalisten
waren nicht zugelassen und er hat sich
geäußert zu der Affäre um seinen vizum
Hubert Aiwanger Patricia Schäfer ist
wieder bei mir bei uns korrespondente in
München um das jetzt gemeinsam hier mit
uns einzuordnen ich fass noch mal ganz
kurz zusammen also hier wurde jetzt
gerade verkündet dass es nur 25 das ist
25 Fragen geben soll jetzt schriftlich
beantwortet werden sollen von Aiwanger
interessant wir dachten ja eigentlich
heute werden offene Fragen geklärt jetzt
scheint das ja noch etwas dauern und vor
allem auch interessanterweise
schriftlich zu erfolgen wie ist das
einzuschätzen Patricia will man da jetzt
Zeit finden ist das eine ganz normale
Sache dass man das jetzt auch
schriftlich haben möchte wie würdest du
das bewerten
also normal ist an dieser Sache glaube
ich gar nichts es ist ein einmaliger
Vorfall den es so in der bayerischen
Staatsregierung noch nicht gegeben hat
deswegen gibt es da keinen das macht man
jetzt normalerweise so oder anders alle
hatten erwartet dass es heute eine eine
Erklärung gibt wie nun weiter verfahren
wird wir haben vorhin die Szenarien
skizziert weiter mit oder ohne Huber
daiwanger weiter mit oder ohne die
Freien Wähler in der Koalition aber man
muss sehen wir sind hier sechs Wochen
vor der bayerischen Landtagswahl am 8
Oktober und
es ist für die CSU andererseits sehr
wichtig dass jetzt zu klären auch für
die Freien Wähler denn es hat auf die
Wahlentscheidung möglicherweise großen
Einfluss von Menschen wie mit dieser
Affäre nun wie die nun ausgeht was
Hubert albern und sagen wird aber es ist
schon eine Art Vertagung wenn man jetzt
sagt 25 Fragen müssen schriftlich
beantwortet werden es wurde von Markus
Söder jetzt gerade gerade keinen
Zeitrahmen genannt innerhalb dem das
passieren soll wir wissen also nicht
wann diese Antworten dann vorliegen
werden was doch verwunderlich ist ist
aber dass so viele Fragen noch offen
bleiben also Markus Söder hat ja in
seinem Statement gesagt wir haben Hubert
Aiwanger befragt und seine Aussagen
reichen nicht aus es bleiben viele
Fragen offen und es gibt noch mehr
offene Fragen das ist doch merkwürdig
wenn man seit 9 Uhr zusammen sitzt jetzt
ist es 12 die Kabinettssitzung wird
nicht viel Raum eingenommen haben es
wird um die causaiwanger und Pamphlet
gegangen sein und so langer Zeit in drei
Stunden keine Klärung herbeizuführen die
man jetzt verkünden kann ist doch
verwunderlich
ich habe einige Fragen bei uns im Stream
gesehen so zum Beispiel von Ralf Müller
der bei Youtube wissen will was steht
denn eigentlich in diesem Flugblatt wir
schauen noch mal drauf hier die
Süddeutsche Zeitung hatte zuerst
berichtet wir können hier mal gemeinsam
auf meinen Bildschirm schauen sind
unfassbar widerliche Worte die wir da
lesen können ich zitiere jetzt noch mal
an zwei Stellen es geht also darum wer
ist der größte Vaterlandsverräter kann
man das eigentlich sehen hier mein
Bildschirm kann man da drauf schalten
wenn das nicht funktioniert also ich
würde hier einen ähm einen solchen
widerlichen Satz mal vorlesen es wird
gefragt wer ist der größte
Vaterlandsverräter dann werden hier
Preise ausgegeben ein Preis so nennt
sich der erste Preis seit Zitat ein
Freiflug durch den Schornstein in
Auschwitz und so weiter und so weiter
nachzulesen unter anderem eben zuerst
berichtet bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung
also auch zu diesem widerlichen Worten
hat sich Markus södert sprach also auch
davon das sei nicht eine bloße
Jugendsünde es sei ein hetzflugplatz
übelster Nazis Jong nichtsdestotrotz
Patrizia lass uns noch mal kurz darüber
sprechen eben über diese Worte es ist ja
seit Tagen schon wird darüber in Bayern
diskutiert muss Söder da nicht reagieren
wie müsste da nicht schneller reagiert
werden wie ist die aktuelle Diskussion
dazu gewesen
also ich finde erstmal die Frage sehr
wichtig und sehr wichtig dass wir wissen
worüber reden wir hier eigentlich es war
da wie so eine Persiflage auf einen
Bundeswettbewerb und dann wurden Preise
ausgelobt es wurde vom
Vergnügungsviertel Auschwitz geredet das
ist also das warum viele in der Reaktion
sagten das ist kein dummer jungen
Streich das muss sich einer wirklich das
spricht für eine Geisteshaltung so etwas
aufzuschreiben wie ist darauf reagiert
worden ja ebenso der
stellvertretende Landtags Präsident also
Landtags Vizepräsident Karl Freller von
der CSU hat gesagt dass
dabei zu haben das schon in seiner
Tasche haben das Verteilen wir wissen ja
nicht was Hubert airwanger wirklich
damit gemacht gesagt wir wissen nur er
hatte ein oder mehrere Exemplare davon
in seiner Schultasche das sei nah am
verfassen also es ist für Karl Freller
in diesem Fall nicht genug zu sagen ja
ich habe es ja nicht geschrieben mein
Bruder hat es geschrieben sondern allein
die Tatsache dass das dabei hatte wenn
das Verteilen hätte wollen das ist
offensichtlich heute ja auch nicht
geklärt worden denn sonst hätten wir
dazu mehr gehört das ist schon genug
alle haben sich
empört gezeigt von allen Seiten alle
Parteien
Opposition genauso wie
Regierungsparteien
fanden den Inhalt dieses verpflegts
menschenverachtend widerwärtig ekelhaft
das sind die Worte die da fallen die
Freien Wähler sagen sie wollen an Hubert
Aiwanger festhalten
nehmen ihn gewissermaßen in Schutz
versuchen der Sache auch ein hinzugeben
in Teilen zu sagen ja das ist eine
Kampagne jetzt kurz vor der Wahl sei das
gegen ihren Chef Hubert Aiwanger und ihr
Zugpferd auch Söder hält ja stand jetzt
an ihm fest da kommt die Frage noch an
Dich von Alexander Strobel bei uns bei
facebook könnte Aiwanger sein Amt bis
zur Beantwortung ruhen lassen war davon
die Rede davon war in diesem Statement
jetzt hier gar nicht die Rede wenn er
das tun würde dann würde er aus seiner
Sicht sehr dass wahrscheinlich aus wie
ein Teil schuldein Geständnis dass würde
er jetzt nicht machen er beantwortet
diese Fragen ich finde enttäuschend dass
wir jetzt keinen Zeitrahmen genannt
bekommen haben also dass wir nicht
wissen wann wird Hubert Aiwanger denn
diese 25 Fragen beantwortet haben was
sind diese 25 Fragen das ist ein
bisschen wenig gewesen was wir hier
bekommen haben Einschätzung von Patricia
Schäfer live aus München vielen Dank
Patricia
ich hatte es eben schon angesprochen
zuerst hatte die Süddeutsche Zeitung
über den Fall berichtet nach und nach
wurden da mehr Details bekannt wir haben
eine Chronologie dieser Ereignisse von
Franziska wunderlich wir schauen
zusammen rein
am Wochenende veröffentlichte die
Süddeutsche Zeitung einen Bericht der
Aiwanger unter Verdacht stellte als
17-Jähriger ein antisemitisches
Flugblatt geschrieben und an seiner
Schule ausgelegt zu haben der bayerische
vizeministerpräsident ließ darauf hin
über einen Sprecher schriftlich
mitteilen ich habe das fragliche Papier
nicht verpasst und erachte den Inhalt
als ekelhaft und menschenverachtend
allerdings räumte Hubert Aiwanger ein
dass in seiner Schultasche damals ein
oder wenige Exemplare gefunden worden
sein als Konsequenz der Schulleitung
habe er ein Referat halten müssen wenig
später meldete sich aiwangers ein Jahr
älterer Bruder und gestand dass beim
Pflege geschrieben zu haben und erklärte
ich distanziere mich in jede Hinsicht
von dem unsäglichen Inhalt und bedauere
sehr die Folgen dieses Tuns ich war
damals total wütend weil ich in der
Schule durchgefallen war
Erklärungen die Ministerpräsident Markus
Söder und dem Rest der Republik nicht
reichen
das sind schlimme Vorwürfe im Raum
dieses Flugblatt ist
menschenverachtend und geradezu eklig
diese Vorwürfe müssen jetzt einfach
geklärt werden sie müssen ausgeräumt
werden und zwar vollständig dazu wurde
heute eine Sondersitzung im
Koalitionsausschuss einberufen
und über das Ergebnis können wir jetzt
auch sprechen mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler karl-rudolf Korte
ist jetzt bei mir schön dass Sie da sind
hallo Herr Korte
ja hallo
sodast CSU die wollten oder wollen
bislang weitermachen mit den Freien
wählernheiten an dieser Koalition mit
aiwangersfreien WLAN fest sehen Sie das
jetzt irgendwie am Bröckeln oder in
Gefahr oder steht das nach wie vor da
das ist nicht wirklich unerwartet weil
die Aufklärung scheibchenweise ja
erfolgt und da liegt auch die größte
Gefahr dass man zwar formal zusammenhält
aber wir wissen das aus anderen dieser
Krisen das ja sehr viele zusätzliche
Informationen in den nächsten Tagen noch
kommen werden unabhängig von der
Beantwortung der 25 fragen da ist ja
eine Schulgemeinschaft die betroffen war
damals da gibt es unzählige Mitschüler
die auch dazu was sagen könnten und
insofern sehe ich nicht ein Ende der
Scheibchen Informationen und damit des
Drucks auf dem Ministerpräsidenten
und schauen wir jetzt auch noch mal auf
weitere Fragen die die jetzt vielleicht
auch noch offen bleiben weil wir haben
ja heute auch nur ein Statement gehört
ein sehr kurzes es sollen jetzt also 25
Fragen schriftlich von Hubert Aiwanger
beantwortet werden interessant in 40
Tagen ist ja auch schon die Bayern Wahl
haben sie Erfahrungen damit wie was
glauben Sie wie schnell sowas gehen
könnte einen Zeitraum haben wir ja jetzt
heute nicht gehört hat uns Patricia
Schäfer ja auch noch mal bestätigt
nee der Ministerpräsident hat sich
erstmal zu seinem Koalitionspartner
bekannt das wird er nicht ändern bis zum
Wahltag aber er hat eine sehr sehr
interessante Formulierung gewählt dass
die Koalition auf die er gerade zu stolz
ist mit den Freien Wählern nicht von
einer Person abhängig ist insofern
rechne ich nicht damit dass die
Informationsflut in den nächsten Tagen
die wir zu dem Thema noch erhalten
werden etwas daran ändert die Koalition
aufzulösen aber das Vertrauensverhältnis
zwischen dem Ministerpräsidenten und dem
stellvertretenden Ministerpräsident ist
ja offenbar vollkommen zerstört denn es
gibt keine transparente Information des
stellvert den Ministerpräsidenten
gegenüber dem Ministerpräsident auch
nicht im Vorfeld und das ist ja eine
misstrauensgemeinschaft die auf keinen
Fall über den Wahltag hinaus trägt
insofern sehe ich
dieser Pressekonferenz ganz klare
Anzeichen dass er gerne mit den freien
wieder weiter zusammenarbeitet aber
sicher nicht mit diesem
stellvertretenden Ministerpräsidenten
hat er sich da jetzt ihrer Meinung nach
mit auf seine Antihaltung gegen einer
Koalition mit den Grünen in ein Dilemma
gebracht
ja es ist an sich immer besser
Optionen zu haben am Wahltag auswählen
zu können aus den Möglichkeiten der
bürgerlichen Mitte sich Partner zu
suchen das ist auch für die
Mobilisierung gar nicht schlecht aber
Süder hat von Anfang an einen anderen
Weg gewählt und kommt von diesem Jahr
auch nicht mehr runter es wäre
absolut unglaubwürdig für die gesamte
Kampagne und die Mobilisierung wenn er
plötzlich jetzt sagen würde er setzt auf
die Grünen und in der Tat die Freien
Wähler sind eine Gruppierung die
bürgerlich mittig organisiert ist
durchaus wertkonservativ sehr passend
zur CSU und insofern gibt es auch keinen
Grund daran zu zweifeln mit solchen
Partner zusammenzuarbeiten und innerhalb
jeder Partei gibt es immer auch
bereitwillige Nachfolgerinnen oder
Nachfolger jetzt so zu tun als würde da
niemand aus der Partei das
selbstkritisch zu sehen dass die
Informationsflut so ist wie sie sich
darstellt daran ist bei keiner Partei zu
glauben es gibt Fragen an Sie bei uns im
Stream von Margarete Steinwender die bei
Youtube wissen möchte warum gibt es
keinen unabhängigen
Untersuchungsausschuss
dazu wäre ja der Landtag in der Lage so
ein zu beauftragen auch die
Staatskanzlei könnte so ein beauftragen
die Möglichkeit ist da
sowas als ein Gremium von der von außen
praktisch zu beauftragen bisher ist das
offenbar nicht gewählt worden man möchte
bilateral ist klären setzt immer noch
auf ein offensives Antworten das
stellverte in den Ministerpräsidenten
aber man kann doch davon ausgehen dass
nach den 25 Antworten auch noch Dinge
offen bleiben werden also es geht nicht
um die Bewertung des
was in der Schule passiert ist sondern
es geht darum wie er mit der
augenblicklichen Situation umgeht und
das ist typischerweise und professionell
wie viele
Spitzenpolitiker in solchen Krisen dann
agieren dass sie eben scheibchenweise
Informationen geben und dass sie immer
in der Defensive sind und von von daher
erwarte ich hier auch nichts anderes ich
glaube auch nicht dass ein
Sachverständigen Gremium von außen dann
am Ende zur Aufklärung wirklich mehr
beitragen könnte zum Schluss noch die
Frage an Sie Herr Korte was glauben Sie
wie das jetzt den Wahlkampf beeinflusst
also schadet das jetzt auch dem
duo-anger Söder sehr dieser Koalition
sehr was da ihre Einschätzung
dass du ist aus meiner Sicht nachhaltig
zerstört weil man sich ja nicht mehr
vertraut was der eine dem anderen
offenbar erzählt und was man hätte
vorher wissen müssen insofern ist ja
eine Basis zerbrochen die werden beide
noch
kämpferisch mobilisieren es gibt auch
Menschen die so eine Kampagne positiv
finden und damit auch die freien wieder
deutlich unterstützen werden aber es
gibt eben gleichermaßen viele die sich
davon auch
abgestreckt zeigen und dem nicht diesen
Weg nicht unterstützen also das
aufzuwägen wie das im Moment für die
Parteienkonstellation aussieht ist sehr
schwer aber das Verhältnis zwischen
beiden Spitzenpolitikern in dieser
Staatsregierung ist auf jeden Fall sehr
gestört und es wird aus meiner Sicht
nicht dazu kommen dass Wählerinnen und
Wähler das auch nicht merken werden dass
dieses Verhältnis ihre Parabel
kaputt ist dann wird das noch mal
spannend 40 Tage vor der Wahl vielen
Dank an sie Professor Prof dr Karl
Rudolf Korte war das vielen Dank
und wir können jetzt noch mal sprechen
mit Patricia Schäfer denn sie hat
Reaktionen auch der anderen Parteien
jetzt schon einsammeln können und weiß
also jetzt wie alle auf dieses Statement
von Markus Söder reagiert haben Patricia
schön dass du noch mal bei uns bist und
uns das jetzt berichten kannst ja also
im Grunde wird Söder schwache Führung
vorgeworfen von der Opposition
SPD-Spitzenkandidat von Brunnen sagt so
da sei eine schwacher Ministerpräsident
er aber nicht den Mut eine Entscheidung
zu treffen und von den Grünen hören wir
Ludwig Hartmann der
Spitzenkandidat neben Katharina Schulze
sagt Söder spielt auf Zeit tatsächlich
keine Frist zu nennen heißt beide sowohl
so oder als auch einfacher haben jetzt
weiterspielraum es heißt aber auch dass
wie oft Korte jetzt schon gesagt hat
dieses Spielchen weitergehen wird wenn
man es ein Spielchen nennen will aber
die Geschichte wird weiter gedreht bis
diese Fragen
antwortet sind man kann natürlich
vermuten dass bis nach der Wahl am 8
Oktober die Frist laufen soll aber da
wird glaube ich der Druck dann doch
höher werden aber es ist ja auch noch
mal klar wirklich bemerkenswert das
Hubert Aiwanger nicht in dieser
Pressekonferenz dabei war das hatte man
eigentlich erwartet dass er mit vor die
Presse tritt er tut es nicht
Söder wollte wahrscheinlich damit zeigen
dass er die Zügel in der Hand hält und
tatsächlich hätte ja einfacher auch in
der Pressekonferenz wenn er die Fragen
nicht beantworten konnte dann weitere
Fragen wieder aufgeworfen also es ist
die Reaktion
Enttäuschung über einen
Ministerpräsidenten der jetzt noch nicht
mal die Karte gespielt hat Hubert
Aiwanger erstmal als stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsidenten auszutauschen der
User Benny hin fragt sich bei uns bei
Youtube ob es auch schon Aussagen der
parteifreie Wähler gibt stehen sie
hinter Aiwanger das erzählen sie sich
wollen sie Partei interne Aufklärung
die Freien Wähler haben Hubert Aiwanger
bisher Rückendeckung gegeben also wie
gesagt vorhin schon erwähnt war aus der
den Reihen der Freien Wähler zu hören
das sei eine Kampagne gegen ihren Chef
es ist auch so dass die bayerischen
Freien Wähler wirklich auf Hubert
Aiwanger angewiesen sind ohne Hubert
Aiwanger würde diese Partei kein
Blumentopf mehr gewinnen so kann man es
deutlich sagen es ist auch der Grund mit
warum die AFD in Bayern weniger stark
ist als in anderen Bundesländern bei der
letzten Wahl 2018 bei 10,2% lag und
Hubert awanger hat vor einigen Wochen in
Erding ja bei einer Veranstaltung sehr
stark in diese Richtung gespielt hat
gesagt die schweigende Mehrheit solle
sich die Demokratie zurückholen er
versucht also hier als freie wählerchef
und in diesem Wahlkampf durchaus im
Becken der AFD auch zu fischen und das
hört man soll die Lehrer die ehemaligen
Lehrer von Hubert eiwanger die ja an die
Zeitungen und dann auch an die
Süddeutsche herangetreten sind mit
dieser Flugblatt Geschichte dazu bewogen
haben dass jetzt eben zu versuchen diese
Geschichte Mal öffentlich zu machen noch
mal die Einschätzung von Patricia
Schäfer vielen Dank
im Vorfeld hatte sich auch Josef
Schuster der Vorsitzende des Zentralrats
der Juden geäußert er sagte das flugbad
das Flugblatt darf aber auch nicht
einfach als Jugendsünde abgetan werden
da ist die für unser Land so wichtige
Auseinandersetzung mit dem
Nationalsozialismus regelrecht mit Füßen
tritt bei uns ist jetzt Hanna Weiler sie
ist die Präsidentin der jüdischen
studierendenunion Deutschlands hallo
schön dass Sie da sind
hallo Frau Weiler wir haben eben Markus
Söder von der CSU gehört sie selbst sind
Mitglied bei den Grünen das soll auch
gesagt sein und damit gehört er sagte
Entlassung wäre Übermaß sehen Sie das
auch so in dieser Sache
also ich glaube es ist zunächst ganz
wichtig
klar zu machen dass junge Jüdinnen und
Juden in diesem Land absolut Josef
Schuster da in seinem Standpunkt
unterstützen
diese Sache darf auf keinen Fall als
Lappalie durchgehen und viel wichtiger
ist dass wir verstehen dass es sich hier
nicht um ein Einzelfall handelt sondern
das ist dieses Gedankengut in
Deutschland nach auch nach 19 45
weiterhin gegeben hat und das ist vor
allem in im privaten Raum und in
Familien weitergelebt hat und albanas
Familie bestimmt nicht die einzige ist
ähm in der solches Gedankengut gegangen
und Gebe war
dementsprechend ich glaube
es hängt sehr davon ab wie sich jetzt
die nächsten Wochen vor der Wahl
gestalten werden wie die Freien Wähler
und wie die CSU sich weiterhin verhalten
werden und welche konsekonsequenzen
gezogen werden bis man
fest sagen kann was die richtige
Entscheidung jetzt ist 25 Fragen sollen
ja beantwortet werden ich möchte auch
noch eine Sache zitieren die hatte der
Historiker Michael wolfssohn bei Bild
geschrieben in einem Gastkommentar er
sagte über das Flugblatt es ist
menschenverachtend aber ist es deswegen
automatisch antisemitisch und hier sie
mieten machen Juden als Juden
verächtlich sie fordern die
Benachteiligung und sogar Ermordung kein
Wort davon in diesem dreckigen Text er
kritisiert dort also die scharfe Kritik
an Aiwanger wie stehen Sie zu dieser
Auffassung
ich glaube dass diese Auffassung für die
jüdische Gemeinschaft in Deutschland
landgefährlich ist ich glaube dass
Michael wolfsson der jüdischen
Gemeinschaft damit absolut kein Gefallen
getan hat denn er unterstützt damit ein
absolutes Missverständnis davon was
Antisemitismus eigentlich bedeutet denn
Antisemitismus braucht keine lebendigen
hüdinnen und Juden um da zu sein und um
sich in einem Land zu entfalten als
diese Methodismus ist eine Welt
anschauen in der ist gut und Böse gibt
und ähm in der es eigentlich überhaupt
nicht um der Alex existierende Jüdinnen
und Juden geht
aber die Konsequenzen dieser
Weltanschauung und die Konsequenzen
dieses Gedankenguts die Treffen mit
voller Wucht lebendige Jüdinnen und
Juden die hier in Deutschland versuchen
ihre Gemeinden aufzubauen und einen
sicher dass jüdisches Leben in diesem
Land zu führen und dieses Schreiben das
trägt nicht zu einem sicheren jüdischen
Leben in Deutschland weiß sondern es
liegt dazu bei dass die Grenzen das sagt
wartet immer mehr geschoben werden dass
immer mehr Menschen sich trauen die
Dinge die in diesem Pamphlet zu Wort
kommen öffentlich zu äußern wenn es so
wenn es doch sogar hochkarätige
politiker:innen machen können ohne
wirklich
große Konsequenzen davon zu tragen und
das Wort Jude ist heute ein gängiges
Schimpfwort auf deutschen Schulhöfen und
ich glaube dass dieses Schreiben und wir
sehen dass an diesem Schreiben das ist
auch in den 80er Jahren so war und ähm
dieses Schreiben fliegt nicht dazu bei
dass die Situation besser wird und die
Position von Michael Wolf sondern ähm
wie gesagt das äh definitiv auch keine
große Hilfe bei der Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus in Deutschland Markus
Söder sagte heute auch in seinem
Statement also in seiner Landesregierung
in Bayern gab es keinen Platz für
Antisemitismus möchte also auch dass
keine Rest Zweifel bleiben sagte aber
auch für ihn jetzt die Recherchen der
Süddeutschen Zeitung die würden nicht
ausreichend für eine abschließende
Bewertung also auch deshalb eben wolle
man so diese Beantwortung der 25 fragen
an Aiwanger abwarten um dann Zitat
vernünftig zu entscheiden so hat er das
gesagt was hatten sie sich erhofft
welche Konsequenzen vielleicht doch
heute schon kommen würden oder warten
Sie nun auch erstmal gespannt diese 25
Fragen ab
also ich glaube ich kann mich an der
Stelle auf jeden Fall Franziska Schäfer
dabei anschließen das ist unglaublich
enttäuschend ist dass kein genauer
Zeitraum festgelegt wurde in dem diese
25 Fragen beantwortet werden sollen ich
habe sehr stark die Vermutung dass auch
Zeit gespielt wird dass man sich erhofft
dass andere Themen und relevanter werden
das ist Vergessenheit gerät und nach und
nach einfach nicht mehr so laut
diskutiert wird
ich glaube was sinnvolle Konsequenzen
unabhängig davon wie die Situation im
eiwanger sich jetzt entwickelt
während einerseits muss es endlich Teil
des schulkultökullums werden dass man
Antisemitismus eben nicht nur im Rahmen
der joa und nicht nur im Darm von was
zwischen 19 und 30 und 1945 in diesem
Land passiert ist dass man eben nicht
nur da drauf guckt aus einem
historisierenden Blickwinkel sondern
dass man dass man versteht dass die
Schuhe in diesem Land
und das rechtsextreme Gedankengut in
diesem Land nur entstehen konnte weil es
dafür eine Grundlage gegeben hat die
Jahrtausende zurückgeht und das auch
nach der sogenannten Stunde Null und
nach 1945 dieses Gedankengut in
Deutschland weiter existiert hat und bis
heute die jüdischen Communitys in diesem
Land tagtäglich trifft das wäre das eine
und das andere was ich mir hoffe wer
eine
Auseinandersetzung auf allen politischen
Ebenen die ich mir vor allem von allen
Parteien in diesem Land erhoffe dass man
in die eigenen rein guckt und in den
eigenen Reihen guckt wie es eigentlich
immer diese Methodismus steht wie es
eigentlich um die Vergangenheit der
FunktionärInnen in den eigenen steht und
so weiter und dass man eben nicht nur so
weit ist und man diese Methodismus geht
mit dem Finger auf die anderen zeigt und
von importierten Antisemitismus spricht
oder Antisemitismus immer nur bei
anderen verteilen aber nicht bei sich
selber vermutet
sagt keiner weil er Präsidentin der
jüdischen Studierenden Union Deutschland
schön dass Sie da waren vielen Dank
das Thema wird uns nun also natürlich
auch noch weiter beschäftigen bis diese
Beantwortung der 25 Fragen von Hubert
awanger geklärt ist wir sind dann
natürlich auch wieder für euch live
berichten ihr seid immer informiert bei
uns bei ZDF heute für heute sagen wir
erstmal vielen Dank bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss